this is a production of cornell
university
okay so today i just want to talk to you
guys a little bit about
my work on trying to model
a couple of different chromatin states
across species directly from dna
sequence and i'm using a flavor of deep
learning model known as a recurrent
convolutional neural network
uh but before i get too deeply into that
i want to contextualize why we might
want to predict within state in the
first place
so we know that accessible chromatin
regulates gene expression and most of
the genome most of the time in vivo is
tightly wrapped around histones and
heterochromatin but transcription
factors bind to this uh accessible
chromatin this open from it's gone to
regular gene expression
we also know that not all these
regulator regions are close to the genes
that they're targeting they can be up to
for example in mains up to 200 kilobases
away so it's important not just to
localize to accessible regions close to
genes but also figure out where they are
in the proportions of genome
and so to put this all together we then
hypothesize that variation within these
accessible regions will lead the
variation of transcription factor
binding which will lead to variation in
gene expression and then go on to
influence all the phenotypes that we
care about
so as a more concrete example of this
there was a study in man across about 40
different traits and two populations
what they did was they took the
partition of the phenotypic variants
that's related to genetics and they
partitioned that further down to
snips that were associated with
different annotation classes
what we can see here is across both
populations about half of the variation
is attributable to sensitive encoding
regions and we expect this more protein
sequence is important
but what's also striking is that uh
variation within accessible regions is
almost as important as variation in
coding so this suggests to me that it's
also very important to
identify where these accessible regions
are if you want to include them improve
prediction models
another important probe in state is dna
methylation and so a recent paper in
grasses showed that if you look at the
chromatin state
across different tissues
you can see that they're all
unmethylated um the accessible regions
and so
what we also know about
dna methylation stayed across
developmental times and it's very stable
and so the suggestion is that if we can
create dna methylation in a specific
tissue then that could potentially
capture the global potentially excessive
space across all tissues
so
predicting chromatin accessibility and
dna manipulation directly from sequence
we have a number of different benefits
the first one is a sequence based model
could be queried to highlight functional
sites and ranking yields it could be
similar to a verb score and really just
serve to narrow down to this top x
variance based on effect size
the second important point is if we get
good cross species models then we'd be
able to predict regulatory regions and
species that we haven't done these
assays and we only have genome
assemblies
this could save time and money by
avoiding is relatively expensive from
its masses
so we know that these accessible regions
are expected to be enriched in
transcription factor binding sites and
so we might use that as a signal to
separately accessible for inaccessible
but unfortunately it's a very noisy
signal because we observe that there's a
lot of spurious matches to transcription
fiber binding sites and inaccessible
regions that aren't functional
so
my hypothesis was that maybe it's really
the order
relative orientation of these motifs
that serve as a stronger signal to help
differentiate accessible from
inaccessible
and what we also know is that these
transcription factor binding domains are
conserved across long evolutionary time
periods and so if we find location one
species we expect them to be observable
also in other species as well for
transcription factor
and so uh convolutional neural networks
have already been shown to be able to
predict chromatin state uh from sequence
within species at least in humans
so we see at the bottom of dc which is a
pretty standard convolutional neural
network which is one of the first
applied to try and predict this problem
and it gets a range of word known as
aprs you can just think of as a metric
for classification performance from zero
to point eight
and then
the year after that dnq was released
which is a recurrent convolutional
neural network which shows improvement
across almost all the test cases
um
the chromatin states and the tissues
that they've tested
um and so my question was can we then
use
dnq to
prevent chromatin accessibility across
species
so
the data they used to train the model
was ataxia data which basically causes
re-pilots underneath the accessible
regions of the genome
then you can take what's known as a peak
color to then binarize this output and
get binary
accessible sequence and accessible
sequence regions
and then i take what's known as umrs
which
you do methylation sequencing on the
genome and you get a methylation state
for all three contexts of dna
methylation you say if it's absent in
all three contexts
and so then again i have
binary on methylated and
methylated freedom
so in total i have training data from
about 12 different species for ataxi
spread nice and evenly across the
angiosperms
for the umr we have about 10 species
five of which are from the original
grasses paper and the five of which are
newly called for this word in the
bodybox
so just a quick overview of how i'm
going to model this i'm taking in 600
base pairs of sequence and i'm centering
it on the
umr the attack cpp and if it's shorter
than that i'll extend symmetrically from
the midpoint
i'll take it the name q which is that
recurrent uh convolutional neural
network an attempt to predict zero or
one inaccessible or accessible
methylated or unoperated
i'm interested in comparing
canvas model we know it works within
species in humans but can it do as well
across species in species it hasn't
observed
and for now i'm going to shorthand and
call this model a to z for arabidopsis
to see
so how does training aesi look like or
within species small so let's say you
want to do it with an arabidopsis scalia
so we're going to take a holdout
chromosome as a test set we're going to
assign these open and closed unlikely
method bins on that chromosome to that
test set
we'll assign the rest of the training
set then i'm going to bounce down from
my training set to make sure they're
equal across open and closed because
this is known to improve classification
training
after that down sampling is done my
training set looks like this in terms of
magnitude 26 000 observations for
species with accessibility and about 36
000 for methylation
then when you evaluate the model in the
test set it looks something like this
for accessibility we get an abr about
0.6
in rapid office transfer methylation a
little bit slightly better at 0.65
so for cross species we're going to
choose a test species of our test set
and we're going to take all of those
within
the test species as our test set
and then assign the rest of the species
into the training set
we're going to dom sample our training
set
then we're going to train the model and
evaluate it and now we get a comparison
how well does within species of
rhodopsidal do to the across species
model that hasn't seen rabidox's
sequence at all
and so when we look across both of these
features you see within its next
accessibility it's quite competitive it
does almost equally as well within
species as it of cross species
less than the case for methylation but
still very close
all right so here are the results across
both features and all my species in my
uh data set so
what's very encouraging is that at least
in accessibility we see a very
competitive uh comparison between the
crossfaces and within species models
it's either equal to or greater than the
ability of the within species model
particularly in grasses with ventilation
the case is
not as strong but it's still there
across all the species that i've seen
before
another thing i want to look at is
whether or not or how large the effect
size is but of a certain transcription
factor
and so the way i can do this is by using
a method called global importance
analysis
the way that works is i'll sample a
bunch of random background sequences in
my case i did a thousand and i used the
base pair frequencies in accessible
regions across the genome to sample
these
and then what i do is i embed a jasper
motif which is a database of about 530
plant tfs
and i just asked the question what's the
difference in prediction
i do this for all a thousand and i take
the pairwise differences and i average
that
and then i embed the motif at all
possible positions then i take the
maximum of that and that's my maximum
global importance score for a given tf
any given species in a given chromatin
state accessibility regulation
then i can rank these tfs by that value
and then a table looks something like on
the right so the first thing to notice
is that
our accessibility between reminiscence
and maze we don't see um
similar patterns so we do see the tcp
location rhetoxis are highly ranked for
accessibility
we see uh in veins that it's also tcp is
highly ranked in the top 10 but it's
also means dot type let's use
um
for the methylation side of things it's
it's more consistent you see basically
the et2 erf
matisse are highly ranked consistently
between both species
as well as these bvr and bbc
family one twos
so in conclusion i've shown that these
recurrent neural nets can model
chromatin accessibility and dna
methylation from sequence and across
species
these across species models are
competitive to models trained only
within species at least within the mds
firms
and the tcp family mates we saw are
entirely global importance to the across
species of accessibility walls
but for the methylation models it is ap2
and erf
and i'm also happy to report that there
is a preprint available that shows what
i've discussed here and also more on
bioarchive
um i've uploaded the data in the models
to xeno which are linked to the
pre-print
and there's code on github which
includes instructions for making your
own progressions in your favorite
species if you'd like
and finally i'd like to acknowledge uh
my community and eric for their guidance
on my co-authors for all the workfields
in making this paper happen
particularly pete he called those extra
dipot uh unlimited reasons for him and
as well as the [ __ ] with that for all
their feedback and the funding sources
and
high performance computing departments
and without it behind
so i asked do you have better hp on
rhodopsis and rice compared with maize
and other species
does this mean the genome complexity of
playing a role yeah that's a great
question i didn't show it here
but i do notice
um a trend so as genome size increases
my performance
increases and what this boils down to is
that the model um i also show this it
makes more false positive mistakes than
it does
so
what i mean by false positive is
the model calls it open but the data is
labeled as closed
and so in these larger genomes that
effect is a lot more pronounced and so i
get
less of an accuracy in those species um
there's a number of reasons why i think
this is the case uh first
the ataxi in the angiosperms was called
very conservatively
but there's a potential that the model
is calling things that are actually open
in vivo but just weren't able to be
captured in the
concerned certainly calling sort of
constraints um
yeah there's also a number of other
reasons but i hope that answers your
question
um do you have a sense of how additive
these motif effects tend to be they
should be fairly active um basically
it's been shown so what's more important
though actually is the businesses
haven't shown the additive to an extent
that they can
sort of interact with each other at the
regulatory site but what's more
important is that they're trying to be
redundant so if you start deleting these
motifs it doesn't necessarily mean that
expression will be impacted and so
that's also a few points
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu